hey youtubers is Charlie you may have
seen the big news this morning Marvel
just teased the beginning of guardians
of the galaxy - they also confirmed some
of the new cast members so this is the
first official picture of the cast the
main cast in costume I know you can't
really see them because they're in a
shadow it's really just meant to be a
teaser like hey we're in costume cameras
are rolling is going down the
bigger news I think isn't so much this
picture I mean we knew they were going
to film those a foregone conclusion
James Gunn has been posting teaser pics
of them doing rehearsals but they have a
couple big names and we know at least
one of the new characters from the
comics they're introducing they're doing
the Mantis character we know that for
sure James Gunn said that it's in the
movie they haven't officially confirmed
her but the actors who's playing her I
don't know exactly how to pronounce her
last name I think it's pong Clement Eve
but this is going to be mantis in the
film she got mixed up with the Guardians
before they did their big reboot when
the first movie came out they done a lot
of different things with the Guardians
team since the movie blew up it's
changed quite a bit but she flew on the
Milano one-upping that they just cast
Kurt Russell in what I think is going to
happen with his character is he won't be
like the official villain of the film
he'll just be the antagonist just like
when they cast Benicio del Toro for the
first film I don't think there's any way
they're going to confirm who Kurt
Russell is playing but I think we're all
in agreement when we say he's probably
going to be Peter Quill's father and it
sounds like just based on Kurt Russell
style just the way he carries himself in
all his films he's going to be starfox
he's going to be Yosef Titan Thanos is
younger brother interesting sidenote fan
OHS is not supposed to be in the film
he'll probably be mentioned but he's not
going to be in the film the way he was
in the first film as a whole other
matter now in the comics I know Peter
Quill's father is Jason of spartax
probably the funniest way to explain it
is the Spaceballs explainer because
guardians of the galaxy is so irreverent
Spaceballs is so irreverent Peter quill
this complete space cowboy as
described by the Nova Corps finds out
that he is the heir to this giant space
Empire this Pardo Empire which is kind
of a Spaceballs thing where it's like oh
my god I'm a prince surprise so yeah the
movies not doing JSON of spartax James
Gunn just said he didn't like that
character you don't want to go in that
direction I think because so much of the
movie is going to revolve around family
relationships it just makes more sense
for them to change it and make Yosef
Titan thing
his brother Peter Quill's father so that
even though the galaxy is this huge
place with all these different comic
book empires it still feels relatively
small like Peter quill could run to the
ends of the galaxy and still would not
be able to escape his family when James
Gunn was writing the movie he was really
cool about doing like periscopes and in
doing q and A's on his Facebook page he
talked a lot about the film in a
roundabout way I mean even give away
spoilers or anything like that but he
did say that fathers were a big deal in
the movie because the biggest question
in the movie is who is Peter Quill's
father and what does that mean for the
galaxy at the end of the first movie
they revealed that Peter quill has some
ancient DNA in him they just you know
very mysterious we don't know exactly
what it is but it's something really old
so if his father really is Yosef Titan
Star Fox we just call him Star Fox his
grandfather Star Fox and Thanos his
father is mentor of Titan
he's one of the Eternals which is like
this weird offshoot of humanity that
went when humanity was first burgeoning
on the earth the Celestials came visited
experimented on humans advanced some of
them genetically they became the
Eternals if you've never read Marvel's
eternals comic think of it as a slightly
different version of the fourth world
done at Marvel now the fourth world is
dark side - DC Comics stuff also Jack
Kirby Jack Kirby also created the
Eternals which is why it sounds a lot
like fourth world stuff so Dano so Titan
flows from Eternals backstory now Jack
Kirby created the Eternals in the 1940s
jim Starlin created Thanos and all those
characters in the 1970s I know it gets a
little confusing when you have a bunch
of different groups in the comics doing
different things and they try to tie
their backstories together but you have
Peter quill then above him you have fan
o so Titan then above him you have his
father who is descended from this Jack
Kirby group of Eternals so Peter quill
theoretically has 50% Eternals DNA in
him let me know in the comments though
do you think that starfox is going to be
Peter Quill's father
they Kurt Russell's going to be playing
him and that will make Peter quill part
eternal explaining why he was able to
hold the Infinity stone without it
vaporizing him and there's a whole lot
of other stuff that we have to explain
about the origins of Titan in half a
nose became evil like what the whole
relationship between Thanos and his
brother is that's like a whole other
video
they've been a couple comics that it
dealt with Thanos's origin story but
remember the movies always change a lot
of stuff from the comics if you want to
read that first appearance of Star Fox
and Thanos though it's in an Iron Man
comic of all places which i think is
kind of funny it's Iron Man vol 1 number
55 it was from 1973 the title is beware
the Blood Brothers but it's not talking
about eros in Thanos the Blood Brothers
are - minions of Thanos but I feel like
it just fits I mean the Eternals look
like people
that explains why Peter quill doesn't
look like some crazy alien he still
looks 100% human you know some powerful
DNA swimming inside of him but there is
another actress named Elizabeth debicki
that was cast for the film I know a lot
of people are wondering maybe she's
playing death if death is going to be a
big part of the Marvel Universe and
Thanos is storyline like it is in the
comics and what better place to do that
than in a cosmic movie like guardians of
the galaxy that takes place in space if
we're theory crafting about Peter
Quill's father we know even less about
what's going on with death in the Marvel
Universe so I'm not going to make any
predictions about who Elizabeth -
Vickie's playing I really like the idea
though if Marvel's going to be changing
a bunch of stuff for their movies if
they make Thanos obsessed with hala
who's the ruler of the Asgardian
afterlife and really really powerful not
quite as big as the cosmic entity death
so don't make too many theories about
what's going on with death in the Marvel
Universe yet there's just too many
questions about it and in terms of
infinity war crossover it sounds like
based on what James Gunn has said like
oh you know we're not gonna directly be
setting that up in guardians of the
galaxy - it sounds like infinity War
part 2 would be where the guardians show
up but all they've really said
officially like James Gunn for instances
is like yeah I have an idea for the
Guardians crossing over with the
Avengers
no I'm not going to talk about it
anytime anybody asks anyone they're like
no no we can't talk about it which is
standard operating procedure for Marvel
like they completely denied that
Benedict Cumberbatch was up for Doctor
Strange until they were like hey we just
cast him remember a year ago when we
lied about it not being a thing that's
just normal studio stuff but I really do
hope that they actually do the cosmic
entity death the funny thing is I've
been talking about Deadpool a lot lately
death itself doesn't really buy into
that oh s--- use kind of swipes left on
cosmic tinder swipes right for deadpool
she totally loves deadpool now you have
to keep in mind that Deadpool is this
really funny comic so that title takes
the character death way less seriously
than when she shows up during
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline so
because of what's going on with all the
studio politics I'm not really expecting
to see the cosmic entity death show up
in the Deadpool movies they'll probably
just make some jokes about it like the
way they joked about only seeing two
x-men over and over it's almost like we
couldn't afford any other characters you
know winking behind the camera speaking
of which I am working on a Deadpool 2
video Deadpool to step up to the x-force
because Deadpool made so much money it
made like a hundred and fifty million
dollars over the weekend over opening
weekend crushing all kinds of r-rated
premiere records they might up the
budget for Deadpool 2 so you might see
more characters more x-force things
going on but I'll talk more about that
in my Deadpool video that'll post
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
that
my next guardians video might explore
some of the lore around Thanos and Titan
there's a lot of interesting stuff there
that we haven't gotten to in the movies
yet why cos wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my flash
video from last night escape from zoom
Mountain news a great episode and you
can click here for all my Deadpool
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you